he's a Justin Hartley the actor and this
is us in a bad mom's Christmas just
recently married brought his wife in
here went into the photo booth and on
all the cute things honeymoon so because
we're filming the show
we're like in mid production right now
he didn't really have time to do a
honeymoon yet so we're gonna do it a
little bit later after we go on hiatus
how did you get engaged so it's a great
question we um I hope this isn't
disappointing you but um we so we're
very lucky we get the opportunity to
sort of travel and go places and things
like that and one of the things I kind
of didn't want to do was do a
destination proposal and that kind of
thing I don't know why I just I wanted
to have it like an intimate you know an
intimate moment and so I decided to do
it at home and I was like oh I'm gonna
ask her to marry me today I was pretty
sure I knew that she was gonna say yes
so it wasn't like I was like you know
that wasn't stressing me out I I kind of
knew where I stood you didn't have a
plan B bin of Len B okay yeah and um and
so I so I was gonna ask her and then I'm
like hey so and then she leaves and
she's like I gotta walk the dog a dog's
gotta go to the bathroom she walks the
dog she comes back and I had bought her
this ring about a year earlier really
delicate sort of gold ring that she
loved and it brought it it broke and so
it was my job to sort of get it fixed
so my delicate it meant cheap cheap yeah
yeah absolutely
she's rowdy you know man she's she's not
yeah she goes out there so I'm so I did
it broken it was my job to fix it and so
I told her I'd fixed it and I gave her
the box I said I fixed your ring and
she's okay fine I kind of turned around
and she didn't she turns around she
opens it up and she looks at it in the
Rings broken still and she's like babe I
don't know how to tell you this and she
turns around I'm on a knee oh wow still
haven't gotten the ring fixed oh it's
okay it's fine now I think yeah I mean
you know yeah that's a solid story
thank you yeah yeah not bad yeah so I
got a surprise in there even though she
knew it was coming I you know tried to
work out does she know if you're acting
at home
yeah yeah I'm not a good actor I can't
like and that's that's my whole thing
I've realized what like late early on in
my career I was like I need to be a good
actor like that's what I want to do I
want to be an actor I need to be a
really good actor and then I realized as
I got older I was like so the key to
that having an acting career is not to
not act really you know what I mean and
so when I'm acting you'll be able to
tell yeah
okay look at my earlier work it's okay
but how did you get this job on this is
us I mean this has been one of the
biggest surprises in network TV in
recent history thank you yeah no I am it
was actually one of the most painless
sort of processes I've been through I
went in I got this script and I read it
my friend said you know Dan Fogelman I
said yeah I know I know Dan Fogelman he
was how long have you known him I said
well I don't know him I know of him I
know I know who Dan Fogelman is and he's
like I just read this script I think he
just wrote you what are you talking
about I never met met the guy really and
I read this script and I I got to the
end of it and I was like this is the
greatest thing I've ever read I gotta
figure out a way to get into this room
so I called my agent he got me into the
room it was a standard audition and they
called me back I had one more on tape
and then they I guess they watched it at
the network and and that was it it was
really painless but what's your strategy
when you go in there because everybody
wants to be an actor but notice in the
room when you know that your future or
yeah I mean there's a lot that ride
you're all right no you're right and you
try not to think about that I guess it's
like sort of a pressure situation kind
of in a big like a bowl game or a Super
Bowl or something like that when you all
it's all on you and you try not to at
least for me you try not to think about
that because that for me again can take
you out of it and sort of take away from
the things that you know how to do and
so I try to just make it like an
intimate one-on-one conversation and try
to just sort of it sounds kind of cheesy
but I really try to just as much as I
can be in that moment of whatever it is
I'm I say I'm doing just try to do that
you know again not acting right but
because of that you got the bad moms
Chris
for that to actually I auditioned for
that too and there with my clothes
stayed on during the audition and so
yeah so I got it I got that one legit -
yeah but okay but did they know of you
from I just I think so I'm okay I think
so I think that I don't want to take
anything away from nomination there I
think you're right I think I got I got
the opportunity probably because of this
is us yeah but then you do take your
pretty said that he went and saw it and
saw a lot of you did you know and then
when you were moonlighting as a stripper
that's right fireman moonlighting as a
stripper watching all too closely
yeah no it's funny that that whole thing
when I read the script I was like ty
swindle I'll write the guy's name is ty
swindle that's good it's always good
when you when your character has a first
and a last name then they're invested a
little bit you know
bartender number three year whatever you
got no shot you're done now do you add
the Swindell well so that's so I was I
called him twice
hi swindle and one of the directors came
over to me he's like no you know what I
think it is he goes I think it's
Swindell yeah and I was like oh of
course it is it has to be Swindell ty
Swindell look what else could it be
and you're working with Kathryn Hahn
Amazo so you she's so funny
uh-huh but then to go and I don't know
how it is when you're with somebody that
if you just look at their face you laugh
sometimes you know Will Ferrell makes me
laugh yeah if you done or Bill Murray
absolutely and Kathryn Hahn is one of
those brilliant performance I couldn't
agree more almost when you're so when
you're saying you're lying and you're
just looking at their reaction and it's
almost not a reaction but he just
started laughing
because she's so funny and the little
things like the ad-libs that come out of
her mouth it's ridiculous they um she's
quick she's really quickly and I love
ad-libbing
and she we did the scene where well
Fritzi you know like where she the
introduction you are where she's she's
at work and I'm her client and I have to
get back man region wax yeah and and I
go in there and they get what they want
and they figure it all out and they they
go well we have a few extra minutes why
don't you guys just just go crazy you
know go nuts if you will and whoa yeah
and I was like okay and so we did one
take where it was just complete ad-lib
whatever they come in they call cut and
I'm like
okay I guess we're done no no the camera
overheated you guys were going for like
eight minutes or something like that
and I it seems like two seconds I was
like eight minutes I felt pretty good
about that but you were allowed to
ad-lib yeah I know they encouraged it
yeah cuz that could be dangerous
sometimes when you know when you're with
somebody who's a professional comedian
yeah yeah
honestly it was easier it was okay I
feel like when you're when you're with
someone who's cuz she knows how to feed
lines and stuff like that too so she's
just she's good all around me she's
fantastic
he's Justin Hartley the show is this is
us Tuesdays at 9:00 on NBC and the new
movie a bad mom's Christmas now in
theaters I saw where your Cubs and
Dodger fan I'm a Dodger fan okay I'm
from Chicago I'm a Dodger no were you a
Cubs fan before you went and sold out
and went to Los Angeles insigh was a kid
my dad took us to spring training when
they were in Florida yeah back in the
day in Vero Beach yep and and I've got
pictures of Steve Yeager Steve Garvey
Orel Hershiser Tommy Lasorda I like
holding me like I'm like when I was a
kid oh well yeah and that cool yeah so
now I go to the games and ice-t like
Garvey's still there yeah his hair is
still magnificent fake right perfect and
and I'm like wow I'm trying to find that
photo because that one of these days I'm
gonna like oh yeah that's you and me
because everything that Garvey does like
he could be an actor yeah he would be
one of those matinee idols back in like
the 50s yeah you know he would be you
know Gregory Peck or somebody like that
but where he just every time he turns
like he's he turns as if there's a
camera waiting to sure get a picture of
him and those forearms are so big and
his hair is always perfect you know it
just piercing eyes he's got it all there
yeah who did you work with who kind of
made you nervous have you had one of
those moments in acting yet uh I you
know what I yeah I've had a few um
sly made me nervous just because of who
he is
Sylvester Stallone me a little nervous
it just because of who he is and he did
an episode of our show yeah and and you
know the interesting thing is about that
guy is he immediately so you're nervous
when he walks in you're like oh my god
that's of us are Stallone and then
within like three seconds you're like
hanging out with a guy
he's just like abnormal it's
unbelievable how he's able to do that
but do you want to ask rocky questions
yeah he'll answer him oh he will totally
yeah yeah no he'll talk about yeah he's
great he'll talk about all that stuff
he's great
didn't he did you want to punch him I
know but I wanted him to punch me I met
Carl Weathers a few years ago no last
year last year and the weirdest thing
happened where I'm at this you do these
press tours for your for the show when
it comes out all these you know you're
going all these interviews and it's a
whirlwind and all of a sudden this guy
walks up to me he goes man I gotta tell
you something and it was Apollo Creed
and I'm like right now I literally I
wanted to say I wanted to say man I'm
such a big fan congratulate this is
great I'm so happy to meet you can I get
a photo and I said oh man I want to
punch me in the face I'm so sorry I said
to Carl Weathers punch me in the face
what am i doing right when did you know
that like things had changed in your
life moment on the street or yeah you
know it what happens with our show is we
tackle some pretty heavy topics and Ryan
Leaf is a friend and my character is
going through this really heavy
storyline right now where he's mental
illness he's got some he's got a an
addiction problem and all that guy stuff
he's kind of like on an island and so I
talked to Ryan Leaf about that and he's
very open you've had him on the show yes
he's fantastic year-round he's
inspirational really and and getting
back to your question when I'm on the
streets and people come up to me and
they tell me their personal stories
these are strangers then they will say
these personal stories about their
family these intimate details and it's
the show that makes them sort of you
know divulge that to it to a stranger
and it's just I mean it's more I don't
even know what to say about that it's so
moving and and just it's beyond it's
it's really like hard to explain what
are you trying when you do you talk to
Ryan were you trying to tap into what AM
what am I gonna feel or what is the
addiction all about I asked him well the
first thing I asked him was you know
can I can I talk to you about it and
would you be willing to and he said of
course yes sure like I said we're
friends and then I asked him I did one
further and I asked him if he could come
in and talk to the writers because we
haven't one of the most amazing writers
they are so creative and I think they're
the best in the business but it's a
roomful of creative people right and so
you get a roomful of big brain creative
people that are smart and funny and God
knows what you're gonna end up with
right because these are brilliant people
so I wanted to make sure that we all
were on the same page and had like like
what this was all about and who better
to speak about that then than Ryan
someone who's turned it all around so
he's a big-time star now who knows if we
get him back on I know this is us bad
mom's Christmas he's Justin Hartley
Congrats on the the marriage thanks man
and we'd love to see it when we're in
Los Angeles yeah that'd be great I'd be
nice and if you would maybe come in and
wear the towel just for it's a date stop
let's take a break the lunch I'm gonna
let you get a hug from Justin before he
leaves all right I may ask for a picture
too because all right okay usually it's
somebody's girlfriend or wife but he
wants one with you that's amazing Justin
Hart could you take off your shirt for
him Justin Hartley for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]